there is a set of characteristics or a
theme that define an optimal diet rather
than one particular dietary brand being
absolutely proven by science as the most
optimal and this theme is that diets
that are low in saturated fat that
provide good amounts of unsaturated fat
that are rich in fiber that have a good
amount of plant protein and a low in
Ultra processed foods time and time
again lead to Good Health outcomes the
cool thing is that there are many
variations of that that could be a
really thoughtfully constructed
Mediterranean diet a really well done
pescatarian diet a really well done
vegetarian diet it could be a completely
plant-based diet so it means that there
are lots of ways to sort of eat your way
to good health